COMMUNITIES THAT ALLOW THEM.
FIRST, THE PANDEMIC PARTY.
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
IF YOU’RE WORRIED ABOUT THIS
PART OF THE CORONAVIRUS, YOU’RE
OBVIOUSLY NOT ALONE.
IT’S UNSETTLING TO SEE DOCTORS
AND WHAT LOOK LIKE HAZMAT SUITS
IN CHINA AND PEOPLE QUARANTINED,
HANGING OUT OF HOTEL WINDOWS AND
A LEAD.
OF COURSE YOUR FELLOW AIRLINE
PASSENGERS WEARING FACE MASKS.
YET MORE UNSETTLING IS SOMETHING
HAPPENING RIGHT HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
IT’S NOT RADICAL.
IT’S POLITICAL.
DEMOCRATS AND THEIR MEDIA
CRONIES HAVE DECIDED TO
WEAPONIZE FEAR AND ALSO
WEAPONIZE SUFFERING TO IMPROVE
THEIR CHANCES AGAINST TRUMP IN
NOVEMBER.
>> TRUMP IS INCOMPETENT.
WE ARE SAYING THIS IN
CORONAVIRUS.
>> DONALD TRUMP IN GENERAL, NOT
JUST WITH THE CORONAVIRUS, BUT
IN GENERAL DOESN’T TAKE
IMPORTANT THING SERIOUSLY.
>> THEY ARE SCARED TO DEATH
ABOUT THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION,
THEY HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THEY ARE
DOING.
>> FOUR WORDS DESCRIBE THE
ADMINISTRATION’S RESPONSE TO THE
CORONAVIRUS.
TOWERING AND DANGEROUS
INCOMPETENCE.
>> Laura: THE PRESIDENT AND
HIS TEAM GAVE US AN IMPORTANT
UPDATE ON HOW THEY ARE BEARING
FOR ANY OUTBREAKS, SHOULD THEY
HAPPEN HERE.
STICK WITH THE NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY FROM OUR STANDPOINT IS
THAT HEALTH AND SAFETY OF AMERIC
PEOPLE.
THE RISK TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
REMAINS VERY LOW.
WE HAVE THE GREATEST EXPERTS IN
THE WORLD.
REALLY IN THE WORLD RIGHT HERE.
WE ARE READY TO ADAPT AND WE ARE
READY TO DO WHATEVER WE HAVE TO.
AS THE DISEASE SPREADS, IF IT
SPREADS.
>> THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
GOING TO CONTINUE TO BE
AGGRESSIVELY TRANSPARENT.
KEEPING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
THE MEDIA APPRISED OF THE
SITUATION AND WHAT EVERYONE CAN
DO.
>> Laura: PERHAPS THEY COULD
HAVE DONE THIS A WEEK AGO BUT
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING IN THE
THING THAT MATTERS TO AMERICANS
COAST-TO-COAST IS THAT THIS
EFFORT IS HIGHLY ORGANIZED,
EXTREMELY THOROUGH, AND VERY
WELL MANAGED.
BUT FACTS DON’T MATTER TO THE
TRUMP HATERS.
THEY LEARN FROM THEY NEVER LET A
CRISIS GO TO WASTE PHILOSOPHY OF
RAHM EMANUEL THAT MANY OF THEM
ARE FRANKLY SO SICK WITH THEIR
ANTI-TRUMP HUMOR THAT THEY
ACTUALLY CONSIDERED THIS VIRUS
APOLITICAL GODSEND.
FINALLY THEY THINK THEY MIGHT
HAVE SOMETHING THAT MAY STICK TO
TRUMP.
LET’S FACE IT.
THEY ARE REALLY FRUSTRATED RIGHT
NOW, THE DEMOCRATS.
THINK ABOUT IT.
AFTER MUELLER FLOPPED, AFTER THE
IMPEACHMENT FAILED, AFTER THEY
CONSTANTLY DEMONIZED TRUMP AS A
RACIST, SEXIST AND EVERYTHING
ELSE YOU CAN THINK OF, THE
ECONOMY AND HIS APPROVAL NUMBERS
CONTINUE TO GROW.
ALL THEY KNOW HOW TO DO IS STOKE
PANIC.
WHAT ELSE DO THEY REALLY HAVE AT
THIS POINT?
I GUESS THEY HAVE BERNIE’S
LAUNDRY LIST OF FREEBIES.
FREE HEALTH CARE, PRE-K,
COLLEGE, HOUSING.
IT’S ALL A FRAUD.
NO ONE TAKES ANY OF IT
SERIOUSLY.
REMEMBER ONE REAGAN TOLD US IT’S
MORNING IN AMERICA AND TRUMP
VOWED TO MAKE AMERICA GREAT
AGAIN AND OBAMA OFFERED HOPE AND
CHANGE.
THIRD 120 DEMOCRATS ON THE OTHER
HAND ARE EITHER HOPING FOR
MISERY OR ACTUALLY PEDDLING IT.
NONE OF THE CANDIDATES HAVE AN
ANSWER TO TRUMP’S BOOMING
ECONOMY SO THEY PRETEND, AS THEY
DID THE LAST NIGHTS DEBATE, THAT
AMERICANS REALLY AREN’T BETTER
OFF AT ALL.
>> WE NEED A STRONG ECONOMY, AND
TO WORK WORLDWIDE ON THAT
ECONOMY.
>> WE ALL KNOW UNCHECKED
CAPITALISM HAS FAILED.
>> FOR THE ORDINARY AMERICAN,
THINGS ARE NOT SO GOOD.
>> Laura: REALLY, BERNIE?
EVEN WITH THE GYRATIONS, THE
STOCK MARKET, EVERY PIECE OF
ECONOMIC DATA SHOWS IN MIDDLE
AMERICA IS DOING MUCH BETTER
THAN THEY DID THREE YEARS
AGO.
NOT TO MENTION THAT AMERICANS
ARE THE HAPPIEST THEY’VE BEEN IN
DECADES.
AND THAT OPTIMISM IS FUELING
MORE PROSPERITY.
JUST TODAY WE LEARNED THAT THE
NEW HOME SALES NUMBERS HIT A 12
YEAR HIGH LAST MONTH.
BUT AGAIN, REMEMBER, GOOD NEWS
FOR YOU IS BAD NEWS FOR THE
MISERY PARTY.
IF YOU AREN’T SUFFICIENTLY
FREAKED OUT ABOUT THE
CORONAVIRUS, YOU SHOULD BELIEVE
THAT AT OUR CORE, AMERICA, WE
ARE JUST A RACIST, ROTTEN
COUNTRY.
>> THERE IS RACISM IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
>> WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH
INSTITUTIONAL RACISM.
>> IF I WERE BLACK, MY SUCCESS
WOULD’VE BEEN A LOT HARDER TO
ACHIEVE.
>> THERE ARE SEVEN WHITE PEOPLE
ON THE STAGE TALKING ABOUT
RACIAL JUSTICE.
>> I AM THE ONLY PER PERSON ON T
STAGE WHO BELIEVES IN
REPARATIONS FOR.
>> SOMETIMES I WAKE UP AND I
THINK IT’S 1920, NOT 2020.
>> IF A CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
THAT IS BROKEN AND RACIST.
>> Laura: CALLED HIM BAD NEWS
BERNIE.
IT’S A WONDER AFTER LISTENING TO
THAT, MARINATE YOURSELF AND THAT
FOR A WHILE.
IT’S A WONDER THAT MILLIONS HAVE
EMIGRATED HERE FROM ALL ACROSS
THE GLOBE, MANY OF THE PEOPLE OF
COLOR.
WHY WOULD THEY DO THAT, GIVEN
HOW THE DECKS ARE APPARENTLY
STACKED AGAINST ALL OF THEM?
TERRIBLE, ROTTEN, RACIST
COUNTRY.
YOU WOULD’VE THOUGHT THAT THE
WORD WOULD’VE GOTTEN AROUND BY
NOW.
DON’T GO THERE.
THEY HATE YOU.
IT’S ALL PRETTY WEIRD, THOUGH,
DON’T YOU THINK?
THAT SUCH A RACIST SOCIETY WITH
THE UNEMPLOYMENT AT RECORD LOWS
FOR AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
HISPANIC-AMERICANS,
ASIAN-AMERICANS?
FRIENDS, IT’S FRANKLY JUST -- I
THINK ABOUT THIS.
IT’S PATHETIC AT THIS POINT.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE COMING UP
EMPTY.
THE GREAT AMERICAN COMEBACK IS A
FACT.
EVERYONE WHO WANTS A JOB, WANTS
TO WORK, IS BENEFITING.
THAT’S GREAT NEWS.
IT’S HAPPENING BECAUSE OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP AMERICA FIRST
POLICY.
THAT TAKES US BACK TO WHERE WE
STARTED.
THE DEMOCRATS LATEST DESPERATE
ATTEMPT TO GAIN THE POLITICAL
UPPERHAND WITH NOTHING ELSE HAS
STUCK.
WHEN ALL ELSE FAILS, ARGUE THAT
WE SHOULD JUST SPEND MORE MONEY.
>> THIS PRESIDENT HAS NOT
INVESTED LIKE HE SHOULD HAVE AT
HIS BUDGET.
HE TRIED TO CUT BACK ON THE CDC.
>> HE HAS DEFUNDED THE CENTERS
FOR DISEASE CONTROL, CDC.
WE DON’T HAVE THE ORGANIZATION
THAT WE NEED.
>> INCREASED THE BUDGET OF THE
CDC.
WE INCREASE THE NIH BUDGET.
IF I WERE PRESIDENT TODAY -- HE
WIPED IT ALL OUT.
WE DID IT.
>> Laura: OH, JOE.
ACTUALLY THE FUNDING FOR THE CDC
AND NIH DURING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS HIGHER THAN IT
WAS DURING THE OBAMA-BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
CONGRESS HAS BEEN KEPT FULLY
APPRISED OF THE CRISIS WITH THE
FIRST BRIEFING HELD LAST MONTH
WHEN THE PRESIDENT CALLED ALL OF
THIS A PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY.
AND HE IMPOSED TRAVEL
RESTRICTIONS ON FOREIGNERS
COMING IN FROM CHINA.
>> WE SHOULD ALL BE WORKING
TOGETHER.
SHE’S TRYING TO CREATE A PANIC.
NANCY PELOSI, SHE KNOWS IT’S NOT
TRUE.
ALL THEY ARE TRYING TO DO IS GET
A POLITICAL ADVANTAGE.
THIS ISN’T ABOUT POLITICAL
ADVANTAGE.
WE ARE ALL TRYING TO DO THE
RIGHT THING.
THEY SHOULDN’T BE SAYING THIS IS
TERRIBLE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP ISN’T ASKING FOR
ENOUGH MONEY.
HOW STUPID ANYTHING TO SAY.
>> Laura: IT’S THE TIME FOR
CALM, MEASURED PRAGMATISM, NOT
PANIC AND POLITICAL OPPORTUNISM
BY A PARTY THAT’S BEEN BUFFETED
BY ITS OWN MISSTEPS AND FAILED
STRATEGIES.
IF THEY APPEAR TO BE ROOTING FOR
AMERICANS SUFFERING AND PAIN
DURING AN ELECTION YEAR, I
PROMISE YOU THAT THE VOTERS WILL